in the last video we took the Maclaurin
series of cosine of X we approximated it
using this polynomial and we saw this
pretty interesting pattern let's see if
we can find a similar pattern if we try
to approximate sine of X using a
Maclaurin series and once again I
Maclaurin series is really the same
thing as a Taylor series where we are
centering our approximation around X is
equal to 0 so it's just a special case
of a Taylor series so let's take f of X
in this situation to be equal to sine of
X f of X is now equal to sine of X and
let's do the same thing that we did with
cosine of X let's just take the
different derivatives of sine of X
really fast so if you have the first
derivative of a sine of X is just cosine
of X the second derivative of sine of X
is derivative of cosine of X which is
negative sine of X the third derivative
is going to be the derivative of this so
I'll just write a 3 in parenthesis there
instead of doing all the prime prime
prime so third derivative is derivative
of this which is negative cosine of X
the fourth derivative the fourth
derivative is the derivative of this
which is positive sine of X again so you
see just like coasts of X it kind of
cycles after you take the derivative
enough time and we care in order to do
the Maclaurin series we care about
evaluating the function and each of
these derivatives at X is equal to 0 so
let's do that so for this let me do this
in a different color not that same blue
so I'll do it in this purple color so f
that's hard to see I think so let's do
this other blue color so f of 0 in this
situation is 0 and F the first
derivative evaluated at 0 is 1 cosine of
0 is 1
negative sine of of 0 is going to be 0
so f prime prime the second derivative
evaluated 0 is 0 the third derivative
evaluated at 0 is a negative 1 cosine of
0 is 1 you have a negative out there it
is negative 1 and then the fourth
derivative
evaluated at zero is going to be zero
again we could keep going but once again
it seems like there's a pattern zero 1
zero negative 1 zero then you're going
to go back to positive 1 so on and so
forth
so let's find it's polynomial
representation using the Maclaurin
series and just reminder this one up
here this was approximately cosine of X
and you'll get closer and closer to
cosine of X I'm not rigorously showing
you how close and then it's definitely
the exact same thing as cosine of X but
you get closer and closer and closer to
cosine of X as you keep adding terms
here and if you go to infinity you're
going to be pretty much at cosine of X
now let's do the same thing for sine of
X so I'll pick a new color the screen
should be nice so this is our new P of X
so this is approximately going to be
sine of X as we add more and more terms
and so the first term here f of 0 that's
just going to be 0 so we're not even
going to need to include that the next
term is going to be F prime of 0 which
is 1 times X so it's going to be X then
the next term is f prime the second
derivative at 0 which we see here is 0
let me scroll down a little bit it is 0
so we won't have the second term this
third term right here the third
derivative of sine of X evaluated at 0
is negative 1 so we're now going to have
a negative 1 negative 1 let me scroll
down so you can see this negative 1 this
is negative 1 in this case times X to
the third over 3 factorial so negative X
to the third over 3 factorial and then
the next term is going to be 0 because
that's the fourth derivative the fourth
that's the fourth derivative evaluated
at 0 is the next coefficient we see that
that is going to be 0 so it's going to
drop off and what you're going to see
here and actually maybe I haven't done
enough terms for you for you to feel
good about this let me do one more term
right over here just so it becomes clear
F of the fifth derivative of X is going
to be cosine of X again the fifth
derivative let me do it in that same
color just so it's consistent the fifth
derivative the fifth derivative
evaluated at
zero is going to be one so the fourth
derivative evaluated zero zero then you
go to the fifth derivative evaluated
zero is going to be positive one and if
I kept doing this it would be positive
one time I have to write the 1 as a
coefficient times X to the fifth over 5
factorial so there's something
interesting going on here and for cosine
of X I had 1 essentially 1 times X to
the 0 then I don't have X to the first
power I don't have X to the odd powers
actually and then I just said
essentially have X to all of the even
powers and whatever power it is I'm
dividing it by that factorial and then
the signs keep switching and this is
this is I shouldn't say this is an even
power because you were really isn't well
I guess you can view it as an even
number because it's no I won't go into
all of that but it's essentially 0 2 4 6
so on and so forth so this that this is
interesting especially when you compare
it to this this is all of the odd powers
this is X to the first over 1 factorial
I didn't write it here this is X to the
third over 3 factorial plus X to the
fifth over 5 factorial yeah 0 would be
an even number anyway I don't that's
almost my brain is in a different place
right now and you could keep going if we
kept this process up you would then keep
switching signs X to the seventh over 7
factorial plus X to the ninth over 9
factorial so there's something
interesting here you once again see this
kind of this kind of complementary
nature between sine and cosine here you
see almost this you know they kind of
they're filling each other's gaps over
here cosine of X is all of the even
powers of X divided by that powers
factorial sine of X when you take it's
polynomial representation is all of the
odd powers of X divided by its factorial
and you switch signs in the next video
I'll try I'll do either the X and what's
really fascinating is that e to the X
starts to look like a little bit of a
combination here but not quite and you
really do get the combination when you
involve imaginary numbers and that's
when it starts to get really really
mind-blowing